It might help you to think about
your to do list as an object
called TodoList that contains
objects called Items.
Objects have attributes or properties.
A TodoList will have a title,
a list of Items and
Items will have a description,
an ID, and a completion status.
Objects also have methods,
or actions they can perform.
You will want to be able to add or
remove items from a to-do list.
You will also want to be able to update
it's status from not done to done.
You should also have print methods for
both of them,
because what good is a to-do list
if you can't actually see the list?
Finally, you need a way
to create the object.
That's what the initialize
method is for.
As you continue to work on your program,
you might add to this list and
that's fine.
For now, we're just brainstorming
the basic structure of our classes.
You can always add to this later.